So we talked about how the internet satisfies
the goals of sharing and interconnection and now
let's talk about some of the other goals
that are discussed in the DARPA Design Philosophy
Paper. As we discuss some of these other
goals it's worth considering and thinking about how
well the current internet satisfies these other design
goals in the face of evolving application threats and
other challenges. One of the goals discussed is survivability,
which states that network should continue to work if
even some device is fail, are comprised, and so
forth. There are two ways to achieve survivability. One is
to replicate. So one could keep state at multiple
places in the network, such that when any node
crashes there's always a replica or hot standby waiting
to take over for the failure. Another way to design
the network for survivability is to incorporate a
concept called fate sharing. Fate sharing says that
it's acceptable to lose state information for some
entity, if that entity itself is lost. For example,
if a router crashes all of the state on the router, such as the routing tables,
are lost. If we can design the network
to sustain these types of failures, where the state
of a particular device shares the fate
of the device itself, then we can withstand
failures better. So fate sharing makes it easier
to withstand complex failure scenarios and engineering is
also easier. Now it's worth asking whether
the current internet still satisfies the principle of
fate sharing. In a subsequent lesson, we'll talk
about network address translation and how it violates
the notion of fate sharing. There are other examples where the
current internet's design violates fate sharing
and it's worth thinking about those.